hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the magnus carlson invitational
semifinals we have a very exciting game
between magnus cross and yanni pomniche
the first game ended in a draw
and this is now the second game it's a
really really crazy one i'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it so uh let's dive straight
into it so as you know yesterday
uh young won uh the match by uh winning
one game and the
they drew the the other three so now
magnus needs to win the second day to
force tie break so let's see what
happens
uh magnus witted the white pieces opens
with d4
we have knight to f6 by on uh c4 e6
knight to c3 and the d5 so again nothing
out of the order ordinary a nice queen's
gambit declined
magnus goes for a trade in the center we
have captures captures and
bishop to g5 now with bishop to b4
pinning the knight here and the queen to
a4 with check and this
has been played many times you don't
lose the bishop because black of course
blocks the check with knight
and then the bishop is defended with e3
uh continuing development next you're
going to develop the bishop the knight
castle and so on so here we have h6
asking do you want to move back or
capture on f6 and magnus trade we have
capture sun f6
queen captures and now knight to e2
and this is not the the rarest of moves
but it is it is fairly rare
only a few games in the database uh with
this knights the e2 idea
uh we have castles by on and now there
is one game
that reached this position with the
knights the g3 from 1996 but here we
have a3 by magnus
and it is now only as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so
let's see how ian deals with this uh he
doesn't uh
go back with the bishop rather he trades
once on c3
we have knight captures and now as his
d-pawn is under attack he plays knights
to e7 and next he's gonna go forward
with with his c
pawn so bishop to e2 magnus also wants
the castle and c6 now nicely
strengthening the central pawn with
castles and now
knight to f5 and i'm sure already here
magnus wasn't feeling all that great
because
well you know what happened yesterday
when nepo started bringing his knight
closer to the white king
and now you can already see some ideas
here queen is coming to g6 knight is
coming to h4
there's going to be pressure on g2
bishop might come to h3
so a very uh attacking position uh and
uh
well although uh magnus usually doesn't
mind getting
himself in in a position where his
opponent attacks this is rapid chess so
here everyone minds
uh but magnus still continues with his
play on the queen side so here we have
b4
and now jan starts with the knight the
h4 you could also start with queen to g5
just uh creating sort of an
attack information but jan starts with
knights to h4
and now king to h1 by magnus and this is
a very important prophylactic idea
uh because let's say you try something
like b5 which is white's plan you want
to
make attack this weak c6 pawn problem is
bishop to h3 is coming and then it's
just very ugly the g2 pawn is hanging if
you push it you lose the rook
uh if you capture the bishop it's not
much better queen g6 check if you move
the king this is checkmate so you're
gonna have to block it with bishop to g4
but then f5 you simply attack the bishop
the bishop cannot move
and well black will just have an
overwhelming attack here
so instead after knight to h4 magnus
recognizes that
the attack is happening and he respects
it he plays king to h1
and now everything is perfectly fine
queen to g6 nipple
threatens checkmate here and g3 now
attacking the knight we have knight back
to f5 and now magnus continues with his
attack on the queen side
and pushes b5 uh nipple ignores this he
continues the attack on the king side
with
h5 and now b captures in c6 so another
case of both players ignoring each other
b captures with b captures on c6 and now
rook to g1
makes sense as the bishop is most likely
coming to h3 so it will not be attacked
on f1
and if the position opens up it's very
nice having your rook on the semi-open g
file and
incredible as it is this is exactly what
jan goes for he doesn't even prepare it
he just pushes h4 he
says you can have this pawn uh i just
want to open up
some sort of an attack towards your king
and magnus
uh bravely captures we have g captures
on h4 now with an attack on nipples
queen on g6 so the knight for the moment
cannot be captured
we have queen to f6 now with an attack
on the pawn and magnus just advances at
h5
so no no no worry in the world uh and
now uh well uh nepo is down material and
he needs to find a way how to attack and
the only way to attack is to bring more
attackers into the game but how do you
bring more attackers into the game
the problem is all of your pawns here
are on light squares and
there's no good way to open up this
diagonal or
is there well as it seems young always
finds a way so here
young starts by sacrificing a pawn he
plays c5
and now he offers a pawn here knight
captures on d5 seems to be a free pawn
and this is uh what magnus goes for and
it is the the best move in the position
so knight captures on the e5 and now
bishop to b7 looks very very dangerous
uh so how will magnus defend the
defenders but magnus finds a way he
plays bishop to f3
uh interestingly there was the very uh
very
straightforward queen to d7 uh this is
the
absolute best move here that magnus
missed defending the knight and now
forcing a trade because uh queen
captures bishop is happening and
there's no good way to defend the bishop
now you're either going to defend it
like this then
queens come off the board and then you
play bishop to f3 uh if you by any
chance play something like this then
just queen captures on b7 of course is
happening and then after captures knight
captures with
check black can't recapture and white
wins a a brilliant game
so uh this would have been better but
magnus played a bishop to f3
which is not bad it's just not as great
uh and here nepo uh has to trade so
bishop captures and e5 as
this is well being threatened so bishop
captures an f on the e5 we have bishop
captures by magnus and now
rook a to d8 uh we have queen six
defending the bishop and now offering a
queen trade and theon accepts we have
captures captures and now
c captures on d4 so grabbing that pawn
and here again magnus needs to decide
what to do here whether he wants to
capture maybe he wants to push
e4 chase away that knight and maybe then
try to
attack the d4 pawn afterwards but magnus
instead goes for this
rook lift rook to g5 he wants to kick
away the knight from the defense of the
pawn and maybe have some h6 ideas
you know happening so here a knight back
to e7 not allowing magnus to capture
anything because his
bishop is hanging here so bishop back to
f3
and now d captures on e3 uh and here
magnus just captures back you don't
you don't really gain anything by a move
like h6 just g6 and
uh you you haven't really accomplished
anything for for for the moment so here
f captures an e3 magnus grabs it
and now rook to d3 going after the pawn
magnus
is up a pawn here but it's a double h
pawn so it's hard to say if he will be
able to push for
for something here uh so rook to e5
defending and attacking and now knight
to c8 preparing to shift the knight back
to d6 we have a4 by magnus
and now knight to d6 and here we have
again a very nice end game bishop
against tonight
nepo a little bit better on time nipple
has some eight minutes on the clock
maybe even nine
whereas magnus had some six minutes on
the clock and uh magnus needs to find a
way to win
as he uh has lost the yesterday's match
so he he
can't really afford any and he draws
with the white pieces so here
rook the c1 uh interestingly if you go
rook to d5 here it doesn't
do anything because black can just
capture here and you've accomplished
nothing captures captures you've just uh
equalized in material and now black has
a better pawn structure so after knight
to d6 will rook to c1
and now comes rook to b8 so preparing
rook to b2 to completely cut off
carlson's king from entering the game
and magnus of course
does not allow this he plays king to g2
and now rook beat the b3 a very
aggressive idea by jan
rook the a3 also interesting going after
this pawn but jan prefers the more
aggressive rook eight
rook b to b3 uh and now
rook to c6 by magnus putting pressure on
the knight here
uh for the moment it's uh defended but
uh if you
capture here then it's no longer
defended uh and here you could uh try
bringing the king to
the game via king to h7 but jan decides
to do it via king to f8
so here we have a5 by magnus again very
interesting rook the c7
uh does seem to be more precise because
after
you trade for example rook captures rook
captures and rook captures
you grab the a7 pawn and now you have
the
outside past a pawn which also uh well
you have the bishop guarding the a8
square so it could be
uh very very nice for magnus uh for some
reason magnus doesn't like that he
pushes a5 right away
maybe he thought he can just play that
afterwards but now
f6 bayern now is this one of those cases
that
f6 loses the game uh we'll see so here
we have rook the e6 with a double attack
on the knight
and now knights the f5 bion with a
triple attack now on the e3 pawn
so um here magnus goes h6 and
this is uh well he he couldn't really
defended the pawn here so he decides to
sacrifice one there
uh and you can't capture with the pawn
because then the f6 pawn is weakened so
here ian captures with the knight
knight captures on h6 and now comes
rook to c8 with check again magnus
doesn't like
bishop to h5 which threatens the rook
the e8 checkmate
uh but it it it is a fine idea because
after the checkmate
it has been prevented you've eliminated
one of black's attackers from the attack
so it's not a bad idea
but okay uh we have rooked the c8 to
check by magnus king to f7
and now rook to a6 going after the a7
pawn then you're gonna double up
probably on the seventh rank and then
maybe go for g7
but now nipple also gets a move in rook
d2 check king to g3
and then now knight to f5 with check
uh again there was maybe an interesting
line rook captures an e3
but uh it's not uh easy to it easy to
spot because you constantly have to
figure out what what what white will do
and the time is uh you know ticking
but the problem is if for example white
captures the pawn then king g6 and
that's it you don't really have a a a
defense here if king to f4 just knight
f5
and then white is completely lost
everything is defended rook f2 is coming
that's it
uh but okay nipple went for knight to f5
check right away we have king to f4 by
magnus and now
rook the f2 so sort of going for the
for a very similar idea uh and then now
comes rook captures an a7 with
check the problem is uh king capture sun
f5 is the way to go
uh but it's again hard hard to look for
winning chances there
rook captures on f3 and if king g4 then
you capture
uh this e3 pawn and now if rook to c7
check king to g6 and again
uh the black king is controlling the
white king completely you can't allow a
move like uh
rook to be for check to happen this rook
is cutting off the king completely here
and it's uh well
the the checkmating patterns are are
there so instead after rook to f2 we
have rook captures on a7
check for magnus king to g6 and now
comes
rook c the c7 but now
as well as you might imagine this game
is now
completely winning for jan so feel free
to pause the video here and find the
winning move the only winning move
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on beating the world
champion
yet again and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's not the rook
captures on e3
no but we're going to show why it's not
it's actually king to h6 a weird move to
play
but with it's a fine idea the problem
with the move you
first checked rook captures on e3 is
that white can sacrifice here rook
captures and g7 with check and now you
have to remove the defender knight
captures and now king captures on e3
real captures here and now it's uh well
white will be a little bit better but
it's a draw
uh so instead after this uh like we said
king to
h6 this is absolutely crushing and now
you don't really have a
you don't really have a good move here
magnus tried king captures on f5 but it
doesn't work
uh rook captures an f3 uh
sorry uh after king captures on f5 rook
capture 73 first
the problem with rook captures here is
that you allow the king to go back with
king to e4 so it's a good thing yan
didn't do that
yan just captured here on e3 and now the
white king has nowhere to go
all of the squares are nicely covered
here and well rook captures bishop is
coming so here
magnus tried rook to c5 but it doesn't
help
g6 with check we have king to g4 and
here
rook f captures on f3 was played and it
was in this position on
46 that world champion magnus carlson
resigned as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
checkmate is coming or rather
the rook uh on the uh on the fifth rank
is preventing checkmate but at what cost
here
whatever you play let's say you play
something rook to a6 it doesn't really
matter
f5 a check on the next move will force
magnus to give up the rook
uh because his king has nowhere to go so
captures captures nipple would be up a
whole rook and that's just it
so a tough tough game for magnus wasting
the white pieces
on the refusing a draw so many times but
as you've seen
uh there were like three times where
magnus could have played better and uh
you know again the upper hand even some
winning advantage
uh but he missed it and it was more more
than enough for for nepal to
to win the game and take the lead in the
second match as well
so will we see yanipo in the finals well
now magnus needs to win the
both of the uh game three and game four
uh to equalize and then force tiebreak
so we'll see if he can do it
uh or will the candidate surpass the
champion
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh very sure magnus didn't uh i would
like to thank mr hoody guy connor watts
david kimura
uh nicolas virkos and peter smith for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the uh magnus crossing
invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day